así que aquí tenemos a esta niña por
aquí la cual mide 1.7 metros de altura y
está parada a pleno sol ahora bien los
rayos del sol hacen un cierto ángulo con
respecto al suelo hacen un cierto ángulo
con respecto al suelo este de aquí y
dado donde el sol se encuentra justo
habitan su sombra mide 3.1 metros de
largo ahora bien lo que nosotros
queremos encontrar es cuál es el ángulo
que hacen los rayos del sol con respecto
al suelo así que lo que tenga en cargar
justo ahorita es que pausa es el vídeo e
intentes averiguar por ti mismo cuánto
vale el ángulo que hacen los rayos del
sol con respecto al suelo o este ángulo
que tenemos aquí este ángulo que
nosotros tenemos aquí pausa el vídeo e
intenta encontrar cuánto vale este
ángulo usando como unidad los radiales
muy bien ahora que estoy suponiendo que
ella pausa este vídeo vamos a imaginar
que aquí tenemos este ángulo y si te das
cuenta también tenemos dos lados este
lado de aquí y este lado de aquí y
podemos averiguar cuál es la razón entre
esos dos lados así que esto va a tener
que ver con trigonometría y cuál de las
funciones trigonométricas podemos
utilizar aquí con respecto a este ángulo
cuál de ellas está relacionada con el
opuesto y el adyacente y bueno creo que
es bastante buen momento para recordar
el soca toa el sol son el seno de un
ángulo es el opuesto entre la hipotenusa
camps que el seno de un ángulo es el
adyacente entre la hipotenusa y todas
todas la tangente de un ángulo es el
opuesto entre el adyacente y justo lo
que tenemos aquí el opuesto y el
adyacente por lo tanto vamos a utilizar
la tangente de
la tangente desde ángulo que es lo mismo
que el opuesto entre el adyacente por lo
tanto podemos decir que la tangente la
tangente de este ángulo teta de este
ángulo teta esto es exactamente igual al
opuesto lo cual es 1.7 1.7 entre esto
dividido entre el adyacente entre las
decentes que es 3.1 entre 3.1
ok por lo tanto lo que nosotros queremos
averiguar es un cierto ángulo teta
tal que cuando nosotros nos tomamos la
tangente de él vamos a obtener 1.7 entre
3.1 o dicho de otra manera nosotros nos
podemos tomar la función inversa de la
tangente de ambos lados de esta ecuación
una función que se llama el arco
tangente y entonces nos quedarían y
déjame ponerlo aquí entonces nos
quedaría que teta ya que aplicamos la
función inversa de la tangente de ambos
lados de esta ecuación que theta es
igual a la función inversa de la
tangente la cual es el arco tangente el
arco tangente de esto que tenemos aquí
de 1.71
punto 7 que a su vez está dividido por
3.1 por 3.1 ok y esta expresión que
tenemos aquí no está tan fácil de
obtener la un santo el círculo unitario
así que mejor utilicemos nuestra
calculadora para obtener el resultado
así que ya la tengo aquí y lo que
nosotros queremos obtener es la inversa
de la tangente es decir le estoy
pidiendo el ángulo cuya tangente es esta
razón que tenemos aquí a la cual le voy
a aplicar la inversa de la tangente y
déjeme primero ponerle aquí 1.7 ok esto
dividido entre 3.1 ok esto es lo mismo
que esta cantidad de aquí y yo lo que
quiero es la inversa de la tangente de
esto que tenemos aquí ahora antes de
llamar a esta función de inversa hay que
verificar que estemos en las unidades
correctas lo que nosotros queremos es
que
este ángulo no dude en radiales y lo
tenemos en grados por lo tanto hay que
tener cuidado y vamos a ponerlo en
radiales de lujo ahora si lo que quiero
es la inversa de la tangente de esto que
tenemos aquí la inversión a tangente y
es 0.50 y si nosotros lo redondeamos al
centésimo más cercano bueno pues va a
quedar 0.50 es decir que puedo concluir
que aproximadamente que aproximadamente
el resultado de obtener la función
inversa de la tangente de 1.7 entre 3.1
es 0.50 de lujo esto redondeado hasta
centésimos y esto es ni más ni menos que
la medida desde ángulo teta esta es la
medida de este ángulo en radiales
es más puede escribir aquí que es
aproximadamente 0.50 ra
bienes de lujo